tia how we doing this morning good dr d
thanks for taking my call thank you so
much for calling in how can i help
um i'm really struggling with trying to
maintain your relationship with my dad
okay uh one second um back up and talk
directly into the phone there
how's that ah perfect excellent all
right go for it
i'm really struggling with trying to
have a relationship with my dad
uh we just bicker constantly over
any and everything and i i really
struggle with
liking him i love him because he's my
dad and i just want to know how what i
can do
to be a better daughter i guess and to
make the relationship work
when there's so much conflict why is
there conflict where's this where's the
stem from
so my dad my parents were married for 25
years and my dad had
affairs throughout that entire time
the latest affair he had was why my mom
was going through breast cancer
and then 15 years later my dad has
married this woman
okay and so i just struggle with his
life choices i'm sure
he really struggles with the decisions
that he's made and i guess
who he is as a man but i but i do want
to have a relationship with him
why do you want a relationship with him
why do you want a relationship with a
guy that you disagree with
when it comes to values that hurt your
mom over the
quarter of a century and then
you feel like rubbed your nose in it by
mirroring the woman that he was with
while your mom was
going through breast cancer surgery like
what what about that guy do you want a
relationship with
well i guess because my little brother
died my only sibling about a year and a
half ago
and i just don't want to lose that
because it's my family yeah
that if i don't have a relationship with
my dad that's one more person i'd be
losing
yeah i'm sorry about your brother
thank you that shouldn't happen i hate
that for you tia i'm sorry
thank you is your mom still around oh
yes i talked to my mom ten times a day
my mom's great
what does she think about this this
about your old man about this ex-husband
of hers
um you know she is still friends with
him like
they maintain a very healthy
relationship i guess
uh for the sake of my brother's kids
their their grandkids and so my mom
doesn't like talk down about him she
understands where i'm coming from she
understands why i'm hurt
but she doesn't she tells me i need to
do what's best for me
so she doesn't kind of like advise me to
go one way or
another when it comes to my dad so your
your
oh let me ask you one more question has
your dad ever violated your boundaries
has he been ugly to you has you been
supportive
of you forget what he did to your mom
has he been a good dad
financially yes emotionally i would say
no
has he hurt you financially or just not
shown up
so financially he's been great uh yeah
but financially man that ends up being
people wallpaper with that i mean that's
right i mean that's that's just like
fancy twizzlers for grown-ups people who
just throw money at problems
um yeah has he what i'm saying
emotionally is he
abusive to you does he tell you you're a
piece of crap and why'd you do that
or is he just not shown up throughout
your life i would say a little bit of
both
okay and so have you ever talked to him
about
how he makes you feel how you feel about
his new wife
how you feel about what he did to your
mom for 25 years have you ever had that
conversation or does it just leak out in
and he complains to you and you can play
back in this little
death by bb gun situation a little bit
of both
but when i've had when i've tried to uh
address the issues like i'll bring up
the infidelities he'll say that those
aren't those aren't my issues that
my those are my mom's issues and they
have nothing to do with me so he'll shut
that
conversation down you know that's a
gigantic wooden box of dog crap right
yes absolutely okay that's 100
not accurate right
yes i i do know that because i watched
it happen my whole childhood
i was directly affected so
i'm going to give you you called me so
i'm going to be real honest with you
okay
and then i'll give you the first thing
that popped into my head
um at some point you're gonna have to
how old are you uh 39 39
okay exhale real quick
big exhale
i can feel your shoulders tense through
the phone all the way here in nashville
okay now listen at some point you're
gonna have to let the fantasy go
your dad sucks okay
that does not mean he's not worthy of a
relationship
that doesn't mean that he's not somebody
that um
should be in your life
but the your dream of having this
perfect dad
is not real and you got to let it go
because it's wearing you out not him
okay it's exhausting you it's keeping
that
low level hum of anxiety in your heart
all
the time and
after 39 years of this it's becoming
if it hasn't already um
it's starting to depress the way you see
the world the way you interact with
people that you love
you're constantly having a minute
constantly having imaginary
conversations in your head
to him right that are never gonna happen
and those get you worked up and those
get you fired up and those get you all
pissed off
here's the thing your dad sucks man he
cheated on your mom for a quarter
century
when he needed her most he wasn't there
the thing you have in your corner is an
absolute rock star ninja mom
and here's what she's given you she's
given you a model
of i'm not gonna let somebody else's
poison kill me
right now that truly is my mom
there's that old saying in a a hating
somebody is like poisoning yourself and
hoping they die
and your mom knows that and so i'm gonna
talk good about that guy
that absolutely devastated me for a
quarter century yeah they broke up our
family
yeah because at the end of the day
your mom's been through enough she's not
going to let him to continue to do that
to her
right and so the earlier you can
i mean the faster you can get to a place
where this is who my dad is he doesn't
tell the truth
he's deceitful he's not honest he hurts
people around him that's just who he is
once you get to that in your heart
and you stop asking him to be something
that he's never going to be
then you can approach him on his turf
then you can make honest decisions and
assessments about do you want him around
your kids
do you want him around your
relationships do you
want to be in his life when and how and
so the one thing that popped into my
mind as you were saying this was
at some point it'll probably do you good
to approach him like an adult
and um and that's not a slight at you
that came out as like i was i was
clowning on you
i'm saying to have two adults not father
daughter but two adults sit down and say
dad i want to have a relationship with
you here's my history with you
here's how i have absorbed this for the
last 40 years
but i love you because you're my dad
and i'm interested in moving forward
here's my boundaries i need you to be
there for me
i need you to be there for your
grandkids i need you to be honest with
me
i need you to stop seeing the following
four or five hurtful things
i need you to do
have a mulligan i mean you can't get a
mulligan on that for crying out loud
i need you for whatever time we've got
left
to step up and my hope honestly
is that he will fall over on the
whatever table y'all are eating it and
he will weep and say i'm sorry will you
forgive me
he's probably not going to and so
i would be prepared to go into that
meeting ready to forgive him and look
him in the eye and say dad i forgive you
because i'm not carrying your weight
anymore i'm not
i forgive you but i'd love you to be in
my life
under my terms inside of my boundaries
and if you're willing i'd love to have
you and then listen
you do have a small family your brother
unfortunately passed away
i recognize that you don't want to lose
somebody else
but recognize that hanging on to
somebody else sometimes means you're
going to drown
and like the the stewardess on the
airline says you got to put on your
oxygen mask first or everyone around you
goes down
everyone around you goes down so tia
let me know how that conversation goes
with him if you decide to have it
but you're gonna have to put the fantasy
down your dad is who he is
and any amount of wishing and begging
and yelling and fighting isn't gonna
change him at this point
just put it down